welcome to this video for coverage of
the ninth round of the candidates it's a
long tournament but we are nearing the
finish line and this is the last round
before a rest day very important all the
time to get to get to this rest day with
a good mindset let's look at this game
kayaking playing chronic kayaking is on
minus one after this victory yesterday
he has recovered slightly with his first
victory on the scoreboard work ramnik
has played down a draw and still this on
+1 before this round sort of in in
trading around ireland and arnold
closely let's see what happened in this
game okay I can play d4 okay he's mostly
an e4 player but he already has
surprised in this tournament by going
1c4 earlier and he had also played some
surprising opening with black I'm
thinking about it now what was it the
Queens gambit accepted against kramnik
in the first turn was also a surprise he
has prepared some stuff for this
tournament obviously Knight f6 Knight f3
this is already native three on this
level is already a bit a bit suspicious
let's call it like that there is I mean
on this level basically all players go
see far as you keep your options open
nobody is afraid of a budapest or banco
gambit this is just on this lover
considered to be good for white in a way
so why not place you for well well one
reason to go 90 of three other the Queen
porn openings which avoid the quick see
phones and yeah Kramnik played d5 he
obviously wanted to go to a Queens
gambit anyway and
the purpose of the move order with
Knight f6 is to get to the Queens gambit
but to avoid the exchange variation yeah
it's actually this look like wants to go
what's to do the knight on f3 and in
case of 93 is playing the NIMS oh
because he does not want to enter this
line um yeah well after Knight f3 here
White has committed to this night move
so there is no particular reason if you
want to go for the Queens gambit to play
a six now and only after c4 play 85 you
can also start with d5 and there is a
reason for this move because if white
now those for something else then see
form you have from a different set of
lines available to you I'm elaborating
on that because yeah well okay i can
play Bishop f4 yeah the london system
avoiding or critical theory with c4 and
there are different types of the london
system depending on blacks set up here
black is in a way still very flexible
the only commitment that he has made us
he has put a pawn on d5 other than that
he has not done things that limit his
possibilities for example he has not
played to move e 6 he can't play that
for instance here it's not bad news um
but he has the choice now to do it it's
not like after let's say e6 Bishop f4
where at least it's clear that black is
never going to develop the Bishop to g4
the simply not going to happen so in a
way with d5 Bishop a form here black has
a good flexibility you can even consider
to play g6 year which is not a bad news
it will probably transpose to the grid
fault or you can play
well I can't play c6 with chronic played
in in the game he took two minutes on
that around and black also has another
possibility which I actually believe is
by far the best move I really think that
from an objective point of view that
this is the best move and chronic didn't
play that which surprised me as has
played that earlier in rapid chess and
in other games and this is c5 I think c5
here is instantly giving black a very
satisfactory game and this is also well
known by by owned by a theory for quite
a while a bit puzzled why chronic didn't
play that um yeah you have to think
about various um aspects when choosing a
line sometimes the objectively best line
which I really believe c5 is sometimes
the objectively best line has the
drawback that it may be for instance
offer the opponent the possibility to to
just kill the game to a draw yeah this
is then in the specific situation where
you must win a game then the objectively
best line is getting less attractive but
here c5 is not only the objectively best
move probably but also the move that
gives black in my least from my
perspective gives black the best chances
to to also get get the game forward then
get some activity the normal
continuation here is III or C 3 yeah it
usually goes like that and black
attacking the be to pawn and white
normally covers this pawn with the Queen
will be three is just to weakening um I
don't want to get in in in super detail
here on what i can do is i can point you
to a video series that i did from a
youtube channel
I think in 2012 it was where I posted a
series of videos how to combat the
London system as black its I believe an
important subject as you get this
opening very often on a club level and
it is not a bad opening for wide it's
just immensely solid and for black
always a bit of a pest if you really
look for somewhat interesting game and
the opponent is playing that against you
some of those people are really very
boring boring persons who just want to
get dead in the position and and do
nothing this is does not applied to all
of them they're also very ambitious
London players so I'm not bashing those
guys so you need to have something well
respect I can point you to this to this
video series we also talked about
combating the London with g6 and other
setups anyway kramnik didn't play that
he played c6 ok um obviously this move
cannot be a mistake I'm not going that
far but i still believe with c5 you have
better chances III plate novel and
Bishop g4 ok yeah see for now 97-93 e6
this is all very normal I mean black has
played very very common very common
setup that can easily arise from from
the Slav for example if you just let me
put it on the board we if you consider
this position yeah yeah this is well
known type of position where like setup
is completely identical to the one
happening in the game but Dwight of
course has in the game whoops the bishop
on f4 and not on c1 and this is
obviously a huge difference look at this
blacks position is identical but the
white is got the bishop
perform and I think this type of setup
where white has gotten in c4 and 93 is
really too much to to allow I mean it's
not like black is on the ropes here but
the other set up with c5 is just the far
more aggressive one they're quite often
you have the pawn on c5 is black and
actually do the pushing it can easily
happen if white plays some inaccurate
move that black is taking over the
initiative here um ki can plate queen
bee three which is the absolutely normal
means in this position yeah and believe
it or not we come to the critical
position of this game it's a really
early I know but yeah in this position
you would think okay what what should
like do now b7 as a text and well you
need to defend it right yeah and the
natural defense rugby aid is obviously
not on so it's probably a queen move
young Queen here could be a move or
queen to be six another option for black
is also to just capture first on f3 the
most popular way to play this is
actually to take and then play Queen to
be six covering their b7 pond after that
why it has the fairly typical sequence
of moves c5 takes takes a 6b form and
now whoopsie eight this is one possible
way to play that blacks ideas to
continue with possibly Bishop to c7
utilizing the f4 Bishop and in the very
long run black would like to play you
five of course white enjoy some space
advantage here and it's debatable if why
this may be very slightly better due to
a space advantage
or if it just equal you can certainly
argue about that but it's also clear
that when chrome Nick was faced with
queen bee three here this is not exactly
a dream position to have if you let's
say certainly in the back of your mind
think of okay maybe I can do some
complications and actually get a game
going you know cannot draw every game
without a fighter's black yeah well
whatever he thought it's hard to tell he
now took on c4 he took her like 14 or 15
mittens on that it's not clear if the
clocks are correct but he took down and
yeah to be honest this is just this is
almost losing it's very tough to recover
from that I mean white just takes on b7
what else is there of course white is
not going to get to play something like
that and allowing let's say this white
is taking on b7 of course yeah and now
we have a position where black girl yeah
really has a hard time to defend those
two bonds it it seems that this is
actually impossible to do what Kramnik
did and he told in the press conference
he had an idea of course he was not like
blundering it away and was shaking his
head to my the b7 porn he had an idea it
was simply not an idea that worked
played 95 here after the first took on a
three Bishop to g3 f white cannot avoid
that you cannot allow a triplet porn on
here far so here and the main problem
was that in this position Kramnik
beforehand he had played the move Bishop
before and this in fact would be
interesting if it weren't for the simple
reply Bishop takes you for and this is
exactly what he had missed he had missed
that 93 is just allowing Queen before
and this is the position where black and
can almost resign with the clear
conscience into retreat
a queen a three and this is really great
white has an extra porn and the two
bishops against two nights and he has
killed LexA castling rights I just just
disaster yeah simply this Bishop before
move was what Kramnik had based his play
upon and it's not working so um yeah he
went for that trying to keep this pawn
at least for a moment but coyoacán can
just mop up the queenside joe this is
just the tect defended it for a moment
but champion now like needed to take
yeah and we can take stock it's two
bishops against two nights and white
already has an extra pawn and well do
you want to defend c4 passively it's not
even clear that this is possible because
let's say rook caj up to to defend this
white will play a form and a4 and a5 and
then takes e4 I mean what kind of
position is that white even has a big
center now against the the too clumsy
nights just are just disastrous yeah
chrome decker castled and we okay I porn
is upon us upon he just he just took it
and now white is two points up out of
the opening still with the bishop am
yeah okay this you lose but still if you
would have told kayaknya will play the
london system one of the more harmless
opening by reputation i play that and
after 17 moves you've got two extra
points against chronic and are basically
you are winning basically i think he
would have laughed but ok this is the
reality of this game Kramnik is now
trying to blockade the pawns yeah trying
to fix them on dark squares and possibly
with the help of a knight from one of
those squares maybe get back see three
and if you would get back and porn I
mean this would really help but it turns
out that not even that is easily
manageable he M try to irritate a bit on
the King side but it's not really lead
to much and oh yeah white can simply
defend the pawn yeah what happens if
black goes Knight a form yeah White has
a good good defense here just with Luke
v8 exchanging one rook it's just that
two ponds are too much there's also
always this idea of just pushing d5 the
right moment in d6 this pawn is
supported by the bishop and well this in
this for for instance is relatively a
simple win yeah crown Niger really try
to to to continue the fight but it's
simply too much also look at this big
center then the night does not really
have a good a good outpost or anything
to go to everything simply covered by
the pawns and all kayaking is not
letting it slip in any way he took even
the a6 porn and our three palms up but
okay we had this transformation now
White has some five five against three
two pawns on the kingside NDA porn yeah
okay this structure is seriously
compromised but it's not important you
still have the a pawn yeah I don't
really think there is some deep analysis
necessary here you got the Queen's off
and we'll just continue in this position
two pawns the better minor piece and yea
the a porn is just is running
yeah he got to this position Kramnik but
okay the a porn it's supported by the
rookie I'm just from the back and
there's of course still H&G porn so that
many end games white will win by
combining the advance of both pawns the
a porn and this majority this can also
often be combined to a pure attack on
the king and we see that a couple of
moves later yeah why does all the time
in the world now now with the advanced
g5 there are even some meeting ideas in
the mix if white gets the rukon be eight
then g6 would would lead to a mate even
just to to show the general idea put
some students live on the board
checkmate yeah this is a possible mating
idea yeah he went back into the seventh
yeah here you've got the main threat so
black needed to react to that yeah now
White has calculated that he does not
even need to capture on age five yeah
it's simple as that that white does not
even need to recapture h5 quickly the
point is to get a route to be seven
seventh-ranked is very much populated by
blacks pieces and getting a route to the
seventh will exchange one look to
finally break the blockade so that the a
porn can win the game it it it's just a
matter of a couple of moves now check
this happened in here kramnik resigned
for yeah the problem is roughly he's
just losing the house check why couldn't
won't take the rook by the way I'm just
thinking about this this is really what
happened I mean
I have seen this hmm well there isn't
even though there isn't even a stalemate
black has got this yeah I don't know but
this seems that the shadow was played to
see bit wacky why wouldn't he wouldn't
he take the rook yeah okay it's not
really important white was totally
winning earlier so I'm a really really
strange game I mean chronic really seems
to be a in bad shape and installment to
come up with this idea it's really
amazing um he's really making lots of
calculation errors and this is really an
typical for for his play of course he's
a very fine strategic player and and
rarely commits any strategical mistakes
or whatever but he's also a player who
normally does not make many calculation
errors and here we've come across a very
very severe one where you where you
basically base your home or play the
whole play on the fact that in this
position you've got this Bishop b4 move
which is simply not to on do to Bishop
takes you form and the problem is that
you can make sometimes you can make
those small blunders you know our small
inaccuracies and they might cost them
yeah some pressure yeah you you're not
winning immediately or something but
this is just such a big big mistake that
it's basically giving the game away
kayaking is not the kind of player who
lets this kind of chance slip and he did
a good job in converting this
disposition yeah so what is what does
that mean um yeah chronic was on plus
one score before the game and now it's
back to fifty percent which really means
that okay fifty percent five rounds to
go it is very tough to to be positive
about it very very tough
while kayaking is tough one fifty
percent he was on minus 22 rounds before
and then scored two wins it basically
means that he is some in a way back in
it I mean he saw just on fifty percent
but he certainly has gotten huge
momentum now with the two wins scored
and young in the next round he's going
to play let me think about it it must be
a Russian player as he playing he has
played Sevilla he must play and Drake
unless the only am I am I right in that
yeah he must play a draicon and if ki
can somehow gets the win out of it yeah
maybe you know maybe he's starting a big
run now it said it's really unlikely but
it sounds unlikely if you would look at
his play like two runs before we didn't
had mean the winner less belt but now
why not yeah a bit of a a bit of a
strange game I'm really puzzled I mean
chronic being lost after like ten moves
in the opening in the London system with
black really sounds like somewhat
strange joke but it happened okay thanks
for watching